[Music]
Even I can understand the pain of losing someone I believed in. I'll find out if I'm a Sagawa gal in a playful car place.
You don't know anything about that guy, do you
?
Certainly I didn't
know anything, I still don't understand it,
but
the trust called oc is there to use it
Well, it's March  That's why I made you believe me by by I
was aiming for an opportunity to betray you
Asine, who doesn't drink
If I kill you with a fool, I'll see you killed in March There's
no such thing.
At the same time, there's no more than this,
even Takane.  If you say so,
then I'd like to see it, then I'll
show you Rosa Where I regain March
is lager,
stagnation is
days  But it's there to lend a hand
5 the air
[music]
What are you going to do if you can't get the ceremony back
Then kill me?
I'll play with
you on the beach Until I get back the guy who listens,
Ageda If I can't get him back
, then Goto will kill you